hi good evening and welcome everyone my
name is ian shapiro and it's a great
pleasure for me to be able to uh kick
off this event and welcome his
excellency ban ki-moon the secretary
general of the united nations to yale to
give the um
the the walker lecture
on in in international affairs
we're delighted absolutely delighted to
be able to do this this lecture was uh
endowed by the honorable george herbert
walker iii from the yale class of 1953
and the former us ambassador to the
republic of hungary
he established this lecture series in
1986 in memory of his father a
distinguished graduate of the yale
college class of 1927.
i'm i'm pleased to note that
ambassador walker is here with us today
so let's give him a hand and thank him
for making this decision possible
uh the walker lecture is given here at
the macmillan center uh every year and
has uh been there in a very in
uh list of figures has given it in the
past such people as madeleine albright
strobe talbot richard holbrook
manfele ramfele uh sir john major brent
scowcroft and many others
and i've also it's a particular pleasure
for me today that uh
that our president-elect the provost of
the university peter salovey has agreed
to be here as the master of ceremonies
and introduce the secretary general so
peter welcome
thank you all very much appreciate that
i'm pleased to be here this afternoon as
part of the walker lecture
to introduce secretary general ban
ki-moon
as you know he is the eighth secretary
general of the united nations his
priorities have been to mobilize world
leaders around a set of new global
challenges
from climate change and economic
upheaval to pandemics and shortages
of food energy and water
he is sought to be a bridge builder to
give voice to the world's poorest and
most vulnerable people
and to strengthen the organization
itself
ban ki-moon grew up in war and saw the
united nations help his country to
recover and rebuild
that experience was a big part of what
led him to pursue a career in public
service
as secretary general ban ki-moon is
determined to see the united nations
deliver tangible meaningful results that
advance peace development
and human rights
ban ki-moon took office on january 1st
2007 was unanimously reelected by the
general assembly in june 2011
and will continue to serve as secretary
general until the end of 2016.
commitments that have defined his tenure
include promoting sustainable
development empowering women
supporting countries facing crises of
instability
and generating new momentum on
disarmament arms control and
non-proliferation
the title he has chosen for his lecture
is shaping solutions for a world in
transition
please join me in welcoming secretary
general ban ki-moon
thank you provost salovey
let me offer my first of all sincere
congratulations on your
appointment as a next president of this
esteemed university yale
and i thank professor ian shapiro the
director of the whitney and petty
magmilan center for international and
area studies
and of course my deepest appreciation to
ambassador walker who has established
this lecture
series it's a great honor for me to be
one of the many distinguished speakers
to this lecture series
dear
students and distinguished faculty
members
friends of yale community
ladies and gentlemen
it's a great pleasure to be here with
you today
i guess that you came to hear a korean
on the international scene
but i hope you don't mind
i'm not going to dance the gangnam style
today
when
sai gangnam style came to my office a
few weeks ago
the reporters
just relinquished my title as having
been number one known south korean in
the world
i didn't have any regret regrets
i hope that many many hundreds of
thousands
korean
young men or girls women
would become as popular as psy gangnam
style ladies and gentlemen i'm really
honored to deliver
the georgie harvard worker lecture
i have been privileged to work with the
members of his family through many years
through my public service
including both
presidents
bush
41st and 43rd the president both
it is also good to be here on campus
again i was here january 2010
immediately after i think the first day
after haitian
earthquake
happened
i was attending this global colloquium
of university presence
hosted by president levin at that time
president levine and yale community
were very generous enough to provide to
gen to give
very generous
support for haitian victims at that time
and i'm very happy to be back to this
and
one of my greatest pleasure is always to
meet the young students
from whom i really get inspiration and
energy
to really motivate me to work harder and
harder as a secretary of the united
nations
yale is
an extraordinary university
that has made its mark in the united
states
and around the world
and in fact the yale has put its stamp
on the united nations literally
the united nations logo which i'm
wearing now
a symbol of hope for people around the
world was designed by a very
distinguished yale graduate named donald
mclaurin i don't know how many people
you know
among you know this fact
i am really proudly wearing this logo
designed by
one of yale graduates
every day
it sends that message in many ways
our blue helmet of peacekeepers
and
many
voluntary workers around the world
helping many poor and disadvantaged and
vulnerable group of people
i saw that symbol
of the united nations myself when i was
growing up
in south korea
i was born before the end of second
world war
then immediately after
korea was
liberated korea
was attacked by north korean aggression
and during that time
we saw the hope
and
sent
this
hope from the united nations people
believed that
there would come our friends the united
nations led by the united states and the
20 other
united nations member states who came to
support us and rescue us
from
almost being you know collapsed
invaded by the north koreans at that
time
since then to the koreans particularly
myself the united nations has been
beacon of hope even these days
to billions of
young people
even billions of many people the united
nations is a symbol of hope as a beacon
of hope
and i'm humbled to carry
that
beacon and torch of hope to many people
even these days
now let me talk about this logo
the many member states wanted to
have united nations logo to feature the
earth
but they had different ideas on which
side of the planet to show
that mr mclaren's design depicted all
continents of the world
equally
then some people suggested that
there should be links binding countries
together
then some people fear that in such a
case the world looked like
you know
bound by some chains
the mr mclaren used his diplomatic
and wisdom
by
framing the globe
with oliver branches
the timeless symbol of peace this is
what i'm carrying and everybody is
carrying this way
and so the seal was
born
the yale's lasting legacy
to the united nations
the world has changed dramatically since
then since 1945.
there has been dramatic changes in
international and political economic and
social
situations
we are now living
in a time of dramatic transformation
the political landscape is shifting
as people across the world rightly
demand freedom accountability and equal
opportunity
economic landscape is also evolving
but new powers emerge
and global interdependence deepens
the changes are environmental
to as we strive to pull back from
overstepping the planet's natural limits
this is a time of turmoil
vulnerability and change
i'm saying that we are living in an era
of inequality injustice
instability and intolerance
we face a burning question
how do we shape
solutions for a more secure and
prosperous world
in my conversations with the world
leaders
and encounters with people around the
world
i return again and again
to three common themes first
leaders need to listen to their people
very attentively and very seriously
what their aspirations are
the second
all of us need to connect the dots among
the challenges we face
there are many global challenges
starting from climate change energy
food
water
and gender empowerment education
organizations
you name it there are so many so many
problems
recently in rio de janeiro
during united nations conference on
sustainable development member states
have identified the 26 major
challenges which we have to address
if you look at these issues they are all
connected
so we need to link this
through
all these linked
should be
all these dots should be linked
then third
we need to find the linkages not just
among the challenges but link people
between the peoples
and create new new partnerships
and alliances to get things done
that is most effective way to solve
problems in our networked world
let me now focus first
on the upheavals across the arab world
for too long
people
were denied opportunities their dignity
freedoms
their real very voice they have been
neglected and denied
and for too long
too many trading and security partners
of deeply flawed regimes
were content with the repressive status
quo
many leaders who failed to move
with the democratic tunnel of themes
times
indeed who actively and violently
suppressed
their people's aspirations
are now gone from the scene
may not be
at the helms
of their countries for much longer
some most of them have already gone but
still there are some leaders
who must go
but
people are fighting for their rightful
choice and opportunities
but democracy is not assured democracy
it takes sometimes
long longer time than expected it cannot
be established firmly through just one
or two
elections
as several countries pursue transitions
uncertainty shadows hope
in others
leaders seem to think winds of change
will not blow their way at all
i've been saying to the world
this wind will continue to blow
nobody knows where this wind
will blow
there is no sanctuary
no leaders will be
immune
if they are not listening to their
people that has been my continuing
message let me talk about the situation
in syria i'm gravely concerned about
this
the situation in syria this is a top
most
serious
situation
where
this international community must
address
i have been telling president assad of
syria listen to your people
listen what they are asking for you to
do
but in the face of peaceful
demonstrations
he responded he resulted
brutal
brutal force
each day in syria brings new reports of
appalling violations of human rights
and tragic suffering
we even tried to have a very brief pose
during this most
most
important holidays of muslims
holidays called idol ada
just the four hours of post
it was just totally ignored and abused
i was deeply of disappointed that both
sides ignored and violated the ceasefire
the united nations is rushing medicines
and food to syrians inside
and outside the country
there are at least 2.5 million people
who have been displaced internally
and there are more than half a million
people
who took refuge who are now being
accommodated by
the neighboring countries iraq jordan
lebanon and turkey
as winter is approaching
i know that the winter in syria in their
region is very severe
there will be a huge
huge
humanitarian
situations and crisis
even as
we staunch the wounds we have to try to
stop the bloodshed
my message has been
that
at any cost we must stop this violence
we have a four priorities in addressing
a syrian situation first
let this violence stop
whatever the differences and grievances
there may be
then immediately to start a political
dialogue for political resolution of
this issue
military is not
unsold not an option
military solution is not an option
then secondly we have to protect the
human rights and dignity in accordance
with international human rights and
international humanitarian laws
so many people's human rights have been
abused
and thirdly
we have to
provide all this not only provide
assistance we have to make sure that
nobody will be
immune from this
situation
and we have to also have
united
forces united voices
of the people in the region the arab
countries are divided the security
council is divided
and syrians are divided
we are dead looked at three situations
their own people security council
and arab people
i repeatedly warned the government and
opposition
that
they cannot solve this problem
by military solution
syria needs a clean break
from the past
but the transition they need can be
achieved through negotiations and
dialogue
the risks to the wider region are clear
already we are seeing spill over effect
the
relationship the very tense
situation between syria and turkey
between syria and israel
and also lebanon
we have seen all spilling over effect we
have to
prevent
this situation from further
spiraling out of this control
syria is a stark reminder
of how much is at stake
and how much can be lost
if the international community
does not unite for peace
and if leaders do not hit the demands of
their people for empowerment openness
and dignity
ladies and gentlemen let me now turn to
a second
themes
second phenomenon in this 21st century
the complex links among the challenges
we face
trade travel technology and twitter
continue to need the world closer
together
but today it is not just the people
who are more in the interdependent
so are the issues all the issues as i
have said are very
closely interconnected
we will not address
climate change without sustainable
energy
we will not promote decent work
without quality education
we will not defeat hunger and disease
without empowering women
sustainable development requires us to
make
these associations
we can see this clearly in africa's
sahara region
there are nine countries in sahel
comprising 16 million people
among 16 million people more than 4.5
million people
are suffering
from long drought of long spell of
drought
flooding
and climate change impact
we are seeing
again another serious humanitarian
crisis in in the sahel
it again creates a very serious
political stability
instability the people of the sahel are
being profited by repeated shocks
caused by
human beings and natural disasters
lawlessness is allowing extremism
and international crime to take hold
we must deal with these issues in a
comprehensive
way
not as isolated unrelated problems
we must identify the crucial connections
and then drive hard then with integrated
and well planned solutions this is what
i'm doing now i'm going to soon report
to the security council a concrete
and package plan to address the
situation in mali as you might have been
following in the international media the
situation in mali particularly the
northern side
are just terrible the human beings are
just slaughtered
through this
application of a sharia law the women's
are just ignored
neglected and abused
we cannot
just
keep this situation continue like this
way
we know
that we can never do this on our own
we need
a partnership this leads to my third
items
the building partnership among countries
the government may be central actors
but even they recognize the need to
mobilize others celebrities and doctors
ceos and ngos imams and rabbis and
priests
and professors and academics
and students and everybody can play a
role
nobody can address all the issues but
anybody
any of you can play some role
but if we combine these some roles i
think this is what
i'm saying the partnership the united
nations is trying to
forge
stronger and greater and bigger
partnership to address all global
challenges let me say a few examples
our every woman every child
effort aims to save 16 million lives
by 2015.
i believe that this is one of the most
successful partnership campaign which
united nations has raised
to save
16 million
human lives particularly women and
children
when women are giving their lives while
giving newborns
new lives
this we have to
prevent we have to stop this is
untolerable again a situation
then scaling of nutrition
there are many
young children
who cannot live longer than five years
before they celebrate their fifth
birthday
millions of children a time
i have launched last june
zero hunger challenge
there are one billion people even today
who will go to bed hungry
in this world of plenty
it is morally wrong
that people are starving
from
lack of food
we have
i'm told by experts that we have enough
food in this world
but why there is a food crisis
as such
because of the
unreasonable
price hike of food
unreasonable way of distributions
and all this has caused the serious
food problem food security issues i
don't call it at this time food crisis
as such but still if we don't manage
well
we will again meet this food crisis
our global
effort
is focused on sustainable energy
without energy in this world
as you have seen the just even now it is
continuing in new york and new jersey
affected by
sandy a storm
that without energy
this modern society cannot function at
all
no transit transportation no electricity
and no telephones no communications
no schools so we have to provide
energy to all the people around the
world united nations has a very
ambitious target by 2030
we will provide every single citizen
around the world electricity energy
that's
one of our top priorities and i think we
can do it
we are also focusing on education
through a new initiative called
education first
last september
together with
gordon brown former prime minister of
united kingdom and the director general
of unesco i have launched a global
education first campaign
there are 61 million people young people
in the world
who are not able to go to school towards
what just
not able to go to school
they are just illiterate the illiteracy
rate is so high
depending upon which country you go
we have to make all these
people
literate
as you may
have been the following of this
there was again very tragic
things which happened to a young girl
malala yusuf jai used to die in pakistan
the terrorists who attacked the hall
showed what they fear the most
i don't think these are terrorists that
they fear the guns or weapons by the
government
i believe that they what they fear most
are education
maybe girls with a textbook
and that came to my mind
and i tweeted and we
i used the social media and twitters
and sent
this message
then there was
outpouring
responses from international community
the twitter called the girl with the
book
is just a simple and extremely powerful
concept
people all over the world
sharing an image of a girl
reading a book as a message of
solidarity and support for girls
education when people are educated
then
the terrorists or extremists
there's no place for them to stand
they are all educated they are armed
with their intelligence
that is what united nations is trying to
educate all the
young girls and boys around the world
photos this
very small photo
a call with a book reading a book
this has been pouring in from pakistan
egypt cameron brazil japan
and all the worlds beyond
among so many
so many billions of photos
you will find one of mine you know
reading
with my granddaughter a book
this has gotten more than i was told 3
million
followers
in the twitters
so this is what united nations is doing
this may be very small
but even a small concept
trying to educate the young girls
but it can make a huge difference
the student
studying in this very esteemed
distinguished yale university will never
understand this kind of situation
when you go to africa and other
developing world
i was wondering why there are so many
young people just wandering around on
the street at this time of school
they should be all
studying in in the schools but they are
just
wandering around
so we have to
make a change on this matter
ladies and gentlemen
when i think of partnership i come
naturally to the united states
that is because the united nations
and united states are natural partners
the reason i'm
coming to yale university
is one of that
continuing efforts on the part of me and
on the part of the united nations to
reach out to american people
so that american people and united
nations can forge a
stronger partnership because we believe
that united nations and united states
share same ideas and goals of the united
nations charter
it was united states
who conceived the idea
of the united nations
right after world war ii
president franklin roosevelt had
conceived that idea and he even made all
this
chatter
and elena roosevelt
drafted this universal declaration of
human rights therefore we need the
stronger
support and more active
contribution by the united states and
that is why i'm sending this message
through you to many young students
we share an impulse or calling to serve
to feed the hungry
to support the democracy to be generous
and first on the scenes in times of
disaster
and the united nations is indebted to
the united states for hosting our
headquarters in new york city
when
sandstorm
affected all these many hundreds of
thousand people
and
you know
during last week i telephone
to
governors of new york and new jersey and
mayor of new york and i sent a letter of
sympathy to
president
obama
now talking about
president obama this is my first public
opportunity or public speech
to warmly congratulate president obama
on his re-election
you thank you very much
i i didn't have vote
i know that
some of you must have voted for him
but some of
may not have voted him but
this is democracy
when you elect a leader as a president i
think everybody should be united and
rarely behind this leadership
u.s u.n partnership
i expect and i hope will be even
more
strengthened and stronger
and more effective
that's why that's because we share many
goals as i said including ending the
violence in syria
and getting the middle east peace
process back on track
let me say just the few words about
the middle east
as you might have already read in the
newspapers that the palestinians
are trying to exercise their
legitimate right
for
statehood
as the middle east region undergoes
fundamental changes
much is also at stake for israel and
palestinians
the cost of the continued stalemate
and ongoing illegal settlement continues
to rise
with each passing day and each
missed opportunity
the parties themselves
and the world at large have a profound
interest
in a trust and lasting peace a two-state
solution remains the only viable option
to end this conflict
and the occupation
that has endured for almost half a
century
realizing this vision requires more
determination
not more delay
the foundations for peace remain
the u.n security council resolutions
roadmap rfps initiative
and moderate principles there are many
principles and guidelines which really
help
both parties israelis and palestinians
so that they can live
in peace and security and side by side
as neighbors
as you know the issue of palestinian
status at the united nations is once
again in the news
the charter of the united nations
makes it clear
such matters are solely in the hands of
member states
i share the frustrations
that the two-state solution
may seem
ever more distant
as all involved now consider the options
we now
we know that actions have consequences
none of us would want to see harm to the
prospects of peace in the middle east
none of us should act in any way that
would place a return to talk
at risk
there can be no substitute for
meaningful negotiations
as we have warned repeatedly
without strong leadership by the parties
and international community thus
two-state solutions
and the commendable institution building
achievements of the palestinian
authorities are in jeopardy
i once again appeal to all those with
influence
the middle east peace process
is on
life support
do not pull the plug
breathe new life
and hope
for those people
the region and the world cannot wait
i believe that their aspiration for
palestinians for
their
statehood has
long overdue
there must be a solution to this but
this solution should come
from a negotiated settlement
this is what i have been saying to
president abbas and also prime minister
netanyahu israel
to engage in dialogue i was in the
region early this year meeting with the
leadership in the region i may go back
to the region soon to help facilitate
their negotiated settlement on this
ladies and gentlemen
dear students
we also need a strong multilateral
engagement to ensure the success of the
democratic transitions
are on the way across the world
we are pressing to achieve the
millennium development goals
before the end of 2015
we are now discussing very seriously
what the development agenda should be
after 2015 when
we meet the deadline of millennium
development goals
combating climate change
is a paramount challenge
i was very encouraged to hear president
obama on his election night on the
victorious victoria statement
that he mentioned
warming planet
this
just once
just one word
gave a lot of hope to many people
when i issued my statement
congratulating president obama
i mentioned
that he should do more on climate change
and i'm glad
that this
climate change will be one of the top
priorities of a second term at president
obama's administration
world leaders have agreed to forge a
legally binding treaty by 2015
last year in durban
and i'm going to attend
this u.n climate change conference next
month in december in doha
the silence
science has made it plenty clear
that climate change is happening
much faster than one would expect
it's a human being
which caused this
climate change phenomena so it must be
human being it must be we
human being who must prevent
this climate change phenomenon from
further progressing before it is too
late
climate change does not respect the
borders
whether you are coming from united
states or korea japan or africa
there is no border for
nature we cannot negotiate with
nature
we have to
reconcile and fully cooperate with the
nature so that we can hand over this
planet earth to our succeeding
generations in a most
environmentally hospitable and
sustainable way that is our moral and
political responsibility i think
professors i think you have a
very important responsibility to teach
the visions to young students this was
one of the message which i
conveyed to president levin
that
academic community
the educational institutions they have
very important responsibility to play in
addressing the global challenges
together with the united nations
and one
responsibility for you is to teach
young people young generation who will
be leaders tomorrow
to have a bigger vision
bigger vision
to have a vision of a global citizen
the people living in the united states
studying in this
very good educational facilities with
good conditions may not appreciate
what you are enjoying
but what you enjoy now should never be
taken for granted
this should be shared with so many
people around the world
that's what i'm saying
think big
and think globally
even though you may act
locally
then there is no difference between
local and global
when you act locally with a global
vision
you are contributing
to
globalization
there are so many challenges we have to
address
everything i have seen as a secretary
general
convinces me that no country in the
world can do it alone
we need to have a collective
responsibility we have to address all
these issues collectively
maybe united states can lead this
campaign as the most powerful most
resourceful country
but any most resourceful countries
cannot do it alone
you need support of other countries
united nations is ready to lead this
campaign together with the united states
so let us work together
to make this world better for
for all the people who will succeed
on this
planet
we have only one planet earth we don't
have two so we have
responsibility to make this planet earth
sustainable way the sustainable
development will be our top priority in
the coming years again i thank you very
much for your attention
and i count on
professors and particularly young
students to be a global leader thank you
very much
it's
take some questions great
general secretary is willing to take
some questions and why don't we start
right there
maybe also identify your name
and then a follow-up question as well
um
i know that since the beginning of your
term or even before the beginning of
your term
the un has pursued a project called
uni-twin the university's twinning and
networking program
where
the un tries to pair up universities in
developing communities
with
universities in
another country and try to expand this
higher education
in developing countries now it's my
understanding that yale is not a part of
unitoin yet
but formerly i was a student at hendong
with the university in this uniting
project
it's my understanding that the president
of hendon university
is a closer friend of yours as well
he's my personal mentor
and while i was at the university
i uh parted uh i had a chance to partake
in several of the
initiatives and actually wrote a book
about it right here i have a copy of it
here
i have a copy of it here and
i'd like to give this to you as a
souvenir for your visit to um i'll be
happy to give it to you after the
lecture
perhaps you can prove it on your way
back to new york
um and my my question is
how can an institution such as yale
better partner the un in the coming
decade or so and how can us students get
more involved in in various un projects
thank you
thank you very much
the question
sounds
some
korean
focused way but this is not this is a
very good global question
concerning how education
and educational institutions can
contribute and work together with the
united nations when you say educational
training
this is now called what we have termed
academic impact
in fact you know before coming here i
have discussed the length with president
levin
president levin has been actively
participating in what we have
established a
global colloquium of university
presidents
the united nations has organized
a colloquium
with
university presidents like yale
princeton colombia new york
university et cetera several
universities president have been
actively participating in this
2010 january i was here to participate
this global colloquium of university
presence there came about 40
presidents from around the world
where we discuss all
sorts of global
issues how united nations can work with
academic
institutions
this academic impact which was initiated
by the united nations
is
the initiative where
more than 800
international universities
participate from
110 countries korea is one of them the
president kim jong-il of handong
university
is now president of academic impact in
korea in korea branch i met him last uh
last month in october when i was in
seoul and we discussed how
we can strengthen this economic impact
i discussed this matter when
i raised this issue to president living
just about an hour ago whether
yale university could participate
in
academic impact it is only natural
that such a distinguished university
like
yale
could contribute
their
their commitment and their leadership
role working together with other
universities coming from different
different parts of the world
we have about 10 guidelines how to
promote democracy how to promote
human rights how to ensure that the
women
are given
full
and equal opportunities
and how to
address poverty and hunger
and disease
there are many ways
many ways academic institutions can
contribute it's not only teaching some
knowledge
knowledge you will learn
and maybe it may be forgotten
when you graduate when you
engage in some other jobs
but what is important is that in this
academic
institutions professors teach how the
students
the leaders of the future
can become a
community leaders
and global leaders and how they can
contribute their knowledge and
experience to the common goods
this is a main
purpose of academic impact i hope that
the
next president salovey will
consider joining this academic impact
thank you very much thank you okay
come samidar
yes
we'll work our way back
why don't you use the microphone okay
um i'm glad to hear that you mentioned
the sahel region and the food security
issues there and i wanted to ask you how
will the un strategy be different from
the one taken in horn of africa where
there have been continuous food security
issues famine that happened in 91 in
somalia again recently and in ethiopia
as well so what is the approach to
actually have a sustainable solution for
these food security issues so that there
aren't these constant famines that are
causing undue
human suffering
challenging
challenges in africa
is one of the top priorities
of the united nations when i
took over my job as a secretary general
in 2007
my first
statement was that we have to address
all these human sufferings in
africa
without addressing this one
we will never be able to claim
that we are living in a world of
harmonious development
where
human dignities
is respected and
promote it
we we can see all sorts of
challenges development challenges
security challenges and human rights
challenges in fact those three
peace and security development human
rights are three pillars of the united
nations charter
so we are very committed we have to make
sure that the all african countries on
board on millennium development goals
all people in africa should be able to
eat without the hunger
and should be able to
get
proper sanitation and healthy cares and
should have
proper education at least the primary
education
so our goal at this time is to provide
all the young students
minimum primary
education
when i said that 61 million people
students
are not
able to go to school that means a
primary school there has been
significant
progress in terms of
providing education in terms of
cutting
by half the number of people
who are hungry
we made a lot of progress i appreciate
the
former president
of world bank who is now here
yes
he i understand that you have just
started the teaching in
here
yes i i really appreciate his
contribution
to millennium development goals and i
really thank you very much this is what
the united nations is doing together
with the world bank imf and the african
union and the european union
and
please note that the
united nations is a foreign committee
to address this human suffering in
africa
thank you
question when we come over here on the
end yes yes
so this might might be a bit of a break
from the policy questions but
here in america we get the new york
times and yale and the dining halls and
we read it and it seems like the new
york times usually focuses on two kinds
of countries one being the countries
that are are western
and what the other being the countries
that are in some kind of serious trouble
so we read a lot about syria we read
about a lot about mali right now
but as the secretary general of the
united nations clearly it's your job to
look out for all the countries not just
the ones that are in the news and so i'm
curious what is your favorite country
that you think most of us don't know
very much about
when
it comes to the job of
secretary general
even though i come from
korea
i do not
talk much about korea
but if you ask me to just singular which
is most
favorite country i should say korea my
home
but
as a secretary general
i have to deal with all 193
member states of the united nations and
there are some countries who are not
even the members of the united nations
so i have to
address all the issues
with the
unmost sense of impartiality
and objectivity
not much about this neutrality
often people believe that
united nations is a neutral organization
but united nations i don't think is a
neutral organization sometimes i cannot
be neutral
i can be impassioned but i have to
criticize when there is a gross
violation of human rights when there is
a serious problem
accountability and perpetrating all
these crimes then i have to criticize
then the other side of the being
criticized may criticize me that i'm
not the neutral
but i am united nations and i am very
impartial
and
regardless where you are coming from
whether you are coming from the west or
east
but there is no difference we are all
human beings we are all
enjoying
fundamental
freedoms and fundamental human rights
the most important thing is that
all human beings
were born equal with the human rights
that we will try
to all what we can we must
to uphold the human rights on the basis
of this human right we have to provide
development we have to secure security
so that everybody can live
in peace and harmony
in a prosperous world this is what the
united nations is doing
very good maybe we'll move to this side
and take the last
question how about all the way in the
back there yep nope that's you
right there
yep yep
thank you for coming um
do you see a future
when
sorry
do you see a future when all nations on
this planet is actually are actually
united and every single one of us will
identify ourselves as the global citizen
thank you that's our
ultimate goal
where all the countries all the people
in the world
can live
peacefully
in harmonious society
unfortunately
this world is really
we have seen so many
unreasonable
intolerable
situations where people simply do not
respect
the belief and conscience and thoughts
and
tradition and cultures and religion of
other people
we have seen such a very very
tragic situation where people are
killing each other because of the
difference of a thought and religion
this is a totally unacceptable situation
the united nations plays a great
emphasis
on promoting
mutual respect mutual understanding
among different people different culture
different tradition
we have established
what is known as
alliance of civilization and this has
gotten broader support
from
international community
but whether they practice
on the principle of alliance of
civilization
that's another matter that's why we are
very much
sad
to see so many so many things which is
happening
in
different parts of the world
i will continue to
promote and raise awareness on this
thank you very much let me thank you all
for your excellent questions and uh why
don't we thank the secretary general one
more time
on behalf of ian shapiro you're all
invited up to the second floor for a
reception
you